[Musique]
nous
chalon vous conter l'histoire les
aventures des aventures
nous allons vous conter l'histoire les
aventures de
on a beau
nous allons vous montrer ce soit
[Musique]
le
m
la veille
le chat qu'on a rebel thibault
[Musique]
quel moment vous amène pas ici je me
rende ce pas chez un paysan dont la
ferme se trouve à peu de distance sa
femme a placé dans sa poche un grand pot
de lunay et j'aimerais bien en connaître
le goût venez avec moi renard si vous
voulez je vous montrerai comment
pénétrer dans le lot se trouverait là de
nombreux poulet c'est avec plaisir que
j'accepte divers
[Musique]
on
oh
q
[Musique]
mieux vaut ne pas vous attaquer aux
poules maintenant car le pays andorre et
elles pourraient le réveiller allons à
la us d'abord nous reviendrons suite ici
vous croyez certains d'autant que le
chien ne tarderait pas à arriver
cela nuirait à mon expédition de la us
ben ben allons à la us
oh
[Musique]
soulève le couvercle renard j'en
profiterai pour pénétrer à l'intérieur
[Musique]
bon ça suffit
tu as eu tout ce que tu voulais à
présent remonte car ce couvercle et
pesant
[Musique]
enfin toi je n'en peux plus
attendre encore un peu
je l'attends
[Musique]